6 22 it's Monday morning Special
Olympics Nevada holding its annual Vegas
plunge the fundraiser is on Saturday
it's not the polar plungers that keep
I've been involved with this for so long
now and I keep wanting to say Polar
Plunge It's Not Special Olympics uh
talking about it here is Elise Pearson
at least good to see you once again hey
thanks for having me I'm excited it's
not going to be a polar punch and it's
80 something degrees this weekend but
nonetheless uh let's talk about before
we get to the the event this weekend
Special Olympics Nevada has been around
for a long time what can an event like
this do for Special Olympics in in its
programs in the valley oh well so we
have so many programs here from Sports
to leadership and health and nutrition
and also everything this year is towards
our goal of Independence we are going to
be an independent Special Olympics
Nevada and all the money we raise here
in Nevada stays here in Nevada so lots
of good things this year now uh full
disclosure I'm on The Advisory board for
Special Olympics Nevada and we've talked
for a long time about trying to get
independence why is that so important
for the mission in in Nevada to be into
dependent from California
better serve our athletes year we need
to be Nevada focused and we need to know
our market and know what our athletes
needs are and the best way to do that is
to be an independent Special Olympics
Nevada and this is a year I'm going to
keep saying it this is a year all right
so let's talk about the the Vegas plunge
happening this weekend out at Cowabunga
Bay it's been going on for a long long
time how's registration right now we're
Rock Solid right now I'm really excited
about it this is you know last year was
really a great year for us and it's
bleeding over into this year another
awesome year was the awesome sponsors a
lot of people excited for this event I'm
excited I never used to get excited for
the Polar Plunge but the Vegas plunge
I'm in too it's a little warmer yeah
it's a little nicer here's some of the
details it's on Saturday again nine in
the morning at a Cowabunga Bay you can
see some of the the money that's
involved for people who want to take
part so talk a little bit about people
teams can donate and contribute after
absolutely so you can register on a team
or as an individual costumes are
encouraged and you know we we have a
costume party and a costume parade it's
a lot of everyone's favorite part we
have a DJ and a hype crew and you come
out you just have a really great time
and then we do a rubber duck Derby and I
think everyone's favorite part is just
watching me Chase the Ducks because I
can never seem to stop them and we have
just a great time and then about 10 45
ish we all line up and dive into the
wave pool at Cowabunga Bay in Henderson
you know one thing that stands out to me
between this event and and the bowling
events they do is it's just the idea of
all the athletes in one place the
interaction with the community how
important is that for the athletes to to
have that interaction that that maybe
goes a little bit outside of their their
normal day-to-day life so absolutely our
athletes love people I mean they're
people people and seeing the support
from their Community just really
encourages and we have I think two
sports happening right now and they take
that into I got don't worry I got the
practices postponed for this weekend
they're all going to be there all right
but they just love seeing the community
come out and support them and it makes
them really feel uh you know that shows
them that they're valuable and they're
important like everyone else love it at
least Pearson from a Special Olympics
better thank you for joining us good
luck at the Vegas plunge good stuff and
we'll have details on 8newsnow.com as
well